so there is another
author who does what I do he writes
books he gives talks he's extremely
smart
and uh you know
I hate him
[Laughter]
you know my my hatred for him is
completely irrational I'm aware of that
um he's always been very civil to me
when I've seen him at events very kind
um he never done anything to hurt me
that I know of he's a good guy I just
have a rational hatred and as a result
of my contempt I'm very very very
competitive with him so I will regularly
go on Amazon and look at his book
ranking and then I'll immediately look
at my book ranking and if he's ahead I'm
angry and if I'm ahead I'm smug
mind you I checked no one else's
rankings it's like it's like as if
there's only two people writing books I
check no one else's rankings just his
right I'm competitive with him
um we had the opportunity to speak at
the same event and I don't mean like me
in the morning him in the afternoon I
mean like we were gonna be on the stage
at the same time interviewed by we're
gonna be interviewed and the interviewer
thought it would be fun if we introduced
each other
and I went first
and I turned to him and I said um
you make me really insecure
all of your strengths are all of my
weaknesses and whenever your name comes
up I get really uncomfortable
and he turned to me and he said funny
I feel the same about you
the reason I was so competitive with him
and the reason I had this irrational
contempt had nothing to do with him it
had to do with me because his strengths
show me my weaknesses it's too difficult
to look at myself and say that I'm weak
here and it's much easier to say I hate
him and I'm going to beat him right now
the funny thing is after that experience
there was a total catharsis all of that
negativity all of that competitive
Spirit completely went away and he and I
now friends and regularly you know
promote each other and help each other
um just hang out together
we live in different cities but yeah if
we're in the same place we'll definitely
hang out together
um
[Music]
um and I and and this is what worthy
Rivals are worthy rivals or other
players in the game whose strengths
reveal to your weaknesses and instead of
trying to compete against them because
you can't beat them there's no such
thing as winning in this game like what
am I there's like what I sell more books
am I the winner you know no right it
means nothing I pick an arbitrary thing
what if it's social media following like
it could be anything what if it's you're
winning anyway like who knows like you
know I mean like the point is it's
stupid and arbitrary right it is
arbitrary he makes 10 times more money
than me am I winning or losing like like
who the hell knows what's your metric
right it's just it's stupid the point is
the comparisons are stupid right
um but what is valuable is that when you
pick players who are better at one or
many things than you are that because
their strengths reveal to your
weaknesses the opportunity is to either
work on those weaknesses to get better
to become a better player yourself or to
partner with them rather than those
strengths and those weaknesses balance
each other off they they uh negate each
other
um and so I'm not competitive I have no
competitors but I definitely have worthy
Rivals people who are really good at
what they do and I have such love and
admiration for them and I used to get
insecure about it but now I'm grateful
because it helps me be a better player
so I'm a great believer in worthy Rivals
and the same goes for companies by the
way you know for companies to compare
each other themselves to each other and
say we're better based on what revenues
profit market share a number of
employees like based on what like based
on what time frame this year total the
next 10 years like it's all arbitrary
and nonsense right not to mention the
fact that most companies are taken down
not by the competitor they're obsessed
with but the one they didn't know of
right you think Myspace even had any
idea that Facebook even existed you know
it doesn't happen you think that the big
TV studios and movie studios were paying
any attention to Netflix exactly you
know you think the big three car
companies were worried about what Tesla
was going to do to upset their
Marketplace like nobody's looking at the
upstarts they're looking at each other
so further reinforcing the Folly of of
arbitrary competition in in business or
in Life or you know in any in any sort
of these infinite games
um so yeah I'm a great believer in
worthy Rivals we should have them
because it makes us better